Julian Herrera ABC 7 News can you talk
about how fun it was to be on the court
with your brother today in the Western
Conference Finals I saw him trying to
get back on defense and once when you
had the ball and just must it's really
special you're the only brothers to ever
do this yeah we've been talking about it
for the last couple of days about how
special you know it is obviously we've
played plenty of games now on the same
court and you you understand what that
vibe is like button on this stage trying
to chase the finals appearance it's it's
pretty pretty surreal I think I caught
myself a couple of times lead over
stands and my parents who did the whole
coin flip thing and they can't help
themselves so anytime either one of us
did something good they both were
clapping so they got a they got to fix
themselves cuz I told my mom like who
you who you wit when I made a shot I saw
her stand up and Cheer but I saw all
Portland this is weird so it's probably
more nerve-wracking for them in terms of
just trying to get settled into what
this series are gonna mean final one
third row center stiff Tony Harvey
Sacramento observer I think we did see
both your parents cheer from both of you
but being out there on that court in
that situation was Seth did it kind of
like bring back memories you know
playing in the driveway again you know
going in and one-on-one with your
brother
it always yeah it always takes you back
there for sure it's on I remember in the
backyard playing playing with each other
one year in high school I watched a lot
of his games too so I get a nice you
know built-in Scout report
you know just watching him locking eyes
on what he does so I think but we
obviously know each other's games
extremely well and a different light
goes off when when you see your brother
across from you so again we're gonna
enjoy this experience and it'll be
something remember no matter how it ends
up for sure